bonjour je les
bons jours julie à france soir je te
demande pardon j'ai fait tellement
absorbé normal et sûr que je ne t'ai pas
entendu arriver c'est certainement livre
très passionnant de quoi s'agit-il c'est
un poème que je voudrais dire aux
enfants de paul fort en sorcier devant
sa maison sursis oui un sursis mais coup
de julie les sorciers ça n'existe pas je
ne sais pas pourquoi mais moi j'ai
l'impression quand je lis ces vieux
compte qu'ils existent il sortit felino
tu as l'intention d'inviter tous ces
gens à déjeuner puis casimir le plus
part je lis tu tu as peur qu'il nous
entende enfin oui peut-être qu'ils
habitent dans la forêt c'est impossible
je reconnais moi les habitants de la
forêt quand il y aller la fin il y a les
maires il ya la bonne heure qu'il ya les
renards enfin je n'ai jamais entendu
parler de donneurs de lutins de
parpaings
ça suffit comme ça maintenant parlons un
peu de choses sérieuses d'accord nous
nous tous les sens avec des sorciers
bien et 6000 ou est-ce que
je t'écoute un désir je viens d'avoir
une idée extraordinaire pas bon ce
serait bien la première fois enfin dit
toujours mersey bon voilà quoi écoute
c'est très facile voilà ce que nous
allons construire
m'énerve c'est de là avec leur messe
basse
pouvais plus m'en occuper tient les
enfants venez je vais vous dire un très
beau poème de paul fort du sorcier
devant la maison nous sommes deux à
l'avoir vu pierre lelong et moi sans
jure pierre lelong le vivien plus est en
plus malin de nature oz près de 1000
bois il faut que vous nous en croyez
nous le vîmes ce pierre et moi danser à
soit sous un poirier la lune au
firmament brillait au doux ciel vert du
crépuscule sautillant sorcier qui hulule
avec des roses lui jongler les jetons si
haut si nombreuse malgré les branches
importune qu'il semblait d'un collier de
rose
lentement enchaîné la lune
bible et de nous deux pierre lelong ils
voient bien mieux
pouvoir y est descendu
et comme une poire perdue
avec tous tes rangement je n'ai pas vu
le temps passer
il fait nuit tant pis je terminerais
dommage n'est pas de langue
ça alors c'est à n'y rien comprendre
je me dis que je n'ai pas là j'y vois
clair
quel silence
j'aimerais bien un peu de musique pour
me tenir compagnie
[Musique]
c'est curieux il semble que j'entends de
la musique
bon va chauffer le dernier carton et hop
je m'en vais
j'ai une faim de loup mais
[Musique]
pour qui ce succulent repas
c'est fait - willy julie pour moi donc à
l'honneur
[Musique]
merci mesdames les faits
je savais bien que françois avait tort
gachet m'en aller maintenant
mais ma robe s'est accroché
j'ai beau tir est elle ne se dégage pas
qu'est ce qui se passe au jour julie
julie je suis là fait détail les paye je
veux je veux lorsque casas d'une bouche
que le bois petite broche dit des choses
très bien madame la fédé taillis
je veux aussi aux sites où tu me disent
bonjour
lorsque tu prouves se moque ce match
toujours madame l'a fait
t'es gentil juges tu peux partir a dit
merci
qu'est ce qui m'arrive je n'ai pas de
chance aujourd'hui mais
une saga que j'ai entendues
alors moi
il écrié
mais qui moi
je suis celui suit le farfadet a des
racines ici est vraiment pas aimables ce
phare fadela
paris hip hop ou julie je suis le lutin
des feuillages
qu'est ce que vous voulez lutte un
effeuillage simplement te dire bonjour
comme je n'ai pas demain mes amis les
araignées mon été à confectionner ce
filet pour te caresser les cheveux
c'est très gentil à vous lutins des
feuillages ça me fait très plaisir mais
j'aimerais bien continuer à bavarder
avec vous un petit peu mais je suis très
en retard je suis très pressé
excusez moi or voir ou revoir julie à
bientôt
tout a marché comme prévu je me suis
quand même un peu écorché les genoux
lorsque j'ai fait là le lutin des
taillis et que j'ai tiré sur la route de
julie c'était très réussi quand même et
moi je fais casimir quand j'ai tiré sur
la corde justement où elle passait en
revue pour faire le farfadet des races
et
le plus drôle c'est quand je suis
mauvais dans l'arbre rouge avec mon
vieux filets de pêche et que je n'ai
laisser pendre pour faire la plaph et
des feuillages
c'était impeccable quand je lis va
revenir à devant d'avoir des choses
il faudrait peut-être cacher le filet
avant qu'elle ne découvre la supercherie
mais tu as raison casimir
casimir tu as entendu on dirait la voix
de mademoiselle fuite est en effet un
des émirs allons-y vite elle a même pas
besoin de secours ah oui la demoiselle
fut tahmineh milani vos mails ou que
vous est il arrivé mais vous
allez passer de la wii c'est tout un
film réfléchissant notamment d'habitude
quand tout d'un
blanc je ne prends pas je vais avait
pourtant bien va pas chez
en quoi ces états unis avant fin mai
mais quoi je fais le droit par l'aca
après bien marché avec julie alors je ne
comprends pas pourquoi
[Musique]